[Music
] artificial intelligence is a
superb tool which already has many
applications in the automotive world and
which will continue to develop in the design phase,
for example it makes it possible to
replace physical models
and improve performance, in
particular for the  smart car
it is used to perceive
the environment and understand
user behavior to
provide the best
mobility experience during
manufacturing artificial intelligence is used
to plan operations and
improve on-line quality
control  for commercial operations,
artificial intelligence makes it possible, for
example, to match the
commercial offer and customer needs in
order to achieve these objectives,
the ai must be developed with
robust methods at all levels
from the qualification of the data
used for its learning until
the verification of these data which
become obsolete
over the life of the system
we do this simply corresponds to
developing a kind of metrology
of artificial intelligence
which will allow us to evaluate the
robustness of its
intelligent functions over time
explainability is  one of these
tools allows you to check that the
mechanisms used by the AI to make its d
cisions are built on good
lues and that it has not, for examp
e, been the victim of bié during its appre
ticeship with the R
nault group  is active in the
French dynamic on
artificial intelligence in the extension of
our manifest participation ago
we are registered in the
research projects of 3 and hannity in toulouse
and 3 i am y aille in grenoble with the
big challenge we  will participate in the
constitution of a development environment
for unia of confidence based on its
research and on this dynamic
our engineers will be able to use on a
daily basis c  and environment to
develop very concrete use cases
such as driving aids
quality control systems or customer relationship monitoring this
is a strong commitment of
the renault group we want to put the
best of technology into
services  that we offer to our
customers and this requires trust
in this technology
[Music]